[Musique]
il s'agit d'un ancien rituel renouvelé dans les villes modernes.
Un samedi matin à 6h du matin, j'ai
rejoint un groupe de bouddhistes que j'avais rencontrés
sur les réseaux sociaux chinois dans un
marché aux poissons de Shanghai. À 10h, des centaines d'habitants de la
ville s'étaient rassemblés pour en
libérer trois.  milliers d'euros de
poisson que nous avons acheté ce matin-là, la
pratique bouddhiste traditionnelle d'Asie de l'Est consistant à
libérer les animaux captifs a
prospéré ces dernières années avec l'essor
des médias sociaux et la facilité des
dons d'argent en ligne, des montagnes de poissons sont
maintenant jetées dans les voies navigables de la ville,
créant  une nouvelle économie pour les pêcheurs et
un sentiment de sens dans une ville de 25
millions d'habitants J'ai grandi à huit mille
sept cents kilomètres à Birmingham,
la deuxième plus grande ville du Royaume-Uni, qui
abrite aujourd'hui plus de cent quatre-vingt-
sept nationalités différentes J'étais le
seul enfant blanc dans ma classe maternelle et
notre calendrier scolaire religieux américain a été
réécrit avec des rituels religieux
célébrant la diversité culturelle et
religieuse  racines de mes amis et
apporter de nouvelles idées de nourriture amusante et d'art dans
la salle de classe J'ai grandi pour devenir
photographe et au cours des deux dernières années,
j'ai observé de telles
célébrations rituelles du couteau dans le monde bien
au-delà de ma classe mon voyage m'a emmené
en France  Italie Ecosse Amérique et en
2013 j'ai déménagé en Chine au milieu de
2009, le nombre de personnes vivant dans
les zones urbaines a dépassé le nombre de
personnes vivant dans les zones rurales et depuis
lors, le monde est devenu encore plus
urbain chaque année une zone de la taille de la
Grande-Bretagne  disparaît sous le béton en
étudiant comment la vie urbaine change sa
clé pour comprendre notre passé et notre
avenir aujourd'hui Je voudrais partager avec
vous comment les rituels religieux sont en plein essor à
Shanghai l'une des villes à la croissance la plus rapide
au monde vivant à
Shanghai depuis trois ans  J'ai été
témoin de la façon dont, par le biais de rituels, les gens
insufflent de l'art dans des structures urbaines stériles
et créent un sens dans les
espaces urbains denses. Il s'agit d'un
plan du métro de Shanghai i  n 1993 et c'est tout juste 20 an
plus tard, c'est maintenant le plus grand syst
me de métro au monde. Ce réseau illus
re l'immense et spectaculaire crois
ance d'une ville et comment il a radic
lement changé sa structure géographique économique et co
necté ses habitants. Shang
ai est connue pour son  dynamisme économique
et audace architecturale super
champion centre commercial super brown est un
plus grand centre commercial en Asie la
société thaïlandaise qui les possède tous a établi un
sanctuaire bouddhiste devant la porte d'entrée
les passants qui passent devant eux
accomplissent tous des rituels qui donnent un sens à
cet urbain stérile  paysage cette
zone d'affaires internationale était une terre agricole
avant les années 1980 les
rituels réguliers auraient amélioré les centres commerciaux les
rituels commerciaux en Chine sont officiellement
limités à cinq taoïsme bouddhisme
protestantisme catholicisme et islam
ces dernières années les pratiques traditionnelles chinoises
ont connu une croissance avec l'
encouragement du  État et population en
quête de sens et de nouvel
environnement urbain  nments J'ai célébré mon premier
nouvel an chinois avec la famille Jeong,
ils ont dressé une table des meilleurs
vins et plats pour les ancêtres, de nombreuses
personnes en Chine ont choisi de
ramener ces coutumes traditionnelles
après que le président Mao a tenté de les
éradiquer pendant la culture.  Révolution de nombreux
édifices religieux différents ont été utilisés
à d'autres fins telles que des blanchisseries ou des
hôpitaux aujourd'hui le rétablissement de l'
Institut taoïste I hi est l'un des trois
centres d'apprentissage en Chine les 50
étudiants des zones rurales autour de
Shanghai étudient pendant six heures par jour et
méditent un particulièrement aéré  et
une salle climatisée bien que les
religions en Chine soient officiellement
limitées à cinq spiritualités alternatives,
les croyances et
pratiques populaires ainsi que les expressions non officielles
des cinq mêmes
religions reconnues fleurissent toutes, apportant une
nouvelle expérience aux citadins Pâques
2016 J'ai rejoint le consulat russe
l'orthodoxie  communauté qui n'est pas une
religion officielle dans  Chine, c'est la
première fois que les Chinois et les
étrangers ont été autorisés à assister à
la riche histoire de Shanghai, les
migrants de Chine et de loin ont acheté de
nouvelles idées que nous avons dans le
tissu urbain le jour le plus froid de Shanghai
depuis plus de 40 ans l'année dernière, j'ai rejoint  un
groupe de travailleurs migrants à manger un bol
de soupe chaude après le service protestant
que ceux qui tenaient dans une usine le
dévouement à leur foi et leur engagement
envers la communauté ainsi que la promesse
d'un copieux bol de nouilles
OOP les ont poussés à se tenir debout pendant deux  heures
à moins huit degrés, le nouveau
développement de Shanghai Disneyland signifiait que l'
usine serait bientôt détruite et que la
communauté cherchait une nouvelle usine
pour organiser son service.
reconstruite et réorientée parsad
I a 99 ans, elle est la plus ancienne femme prêtre
de Shanghai en 1981, elle a été la première
femme à être ordonnée dans la ville.
La maison d'une pièce à côté de l'église est
pleine de la plupart de ses biens
c'est un lieu de rassemblement et de
festin réguliers les réunions dans sa chambre ont
préservé toute l'histoire dont elle fait
partie et inspirent les jeunes adeptes fasho L'ONU
est l'un des principaux  cimetières à
Shanghai la société qui le possédait et l'
entretenait est cotée à la
bourse de hong kong une haute tour au milieu
du cimetière abrite des pièces et des pièces
sur des armoires qui sont vendues à un
prix élevé pour contenir les cendres des ancêtres des peuples
lors des principales fêtes chinoises  les gens
apportent des ornements et de la nourriture pour les
ancêtres qui sont représentés dans chaque
armoire par un portrait photographique les
rituels sont au cœur de ce que
signifie être humain ils marquent le
temps qui passe et amènent l'art au quotidien
ils nous permettent souvent de nous exprimer sans
mots  tout comme la photographie transmet à
travers des images
rituelles le passage du rituel d'un
pays à l'autre permet aux nouveaux
venus de s'installer dans un luxueux
composé de femmes indiennes  à tour
de rôle pour accueillir les célébrations des principaux
festivals hindous dans leurs appartements, la
communauté choisit un composé en raison de sa
proximité avec la rivière Huangpu
ici, les hindous disent leurs prières quotidiennes à
cette vue majestueuse reflétant le
rôle central du fleuve sacré Gange pour les hindous
dans  Inde La cérémonie du feu de plomb du yogi indien
pour les dévots chinois sur la
charmante île la croissance du yoga a
encouragé de nombreux Chinois différents à
suivre différentes pratiques telles que ces
rituels ont permis la transmission de
diverses croyances et idées dans cette
immense ville tout au long de son histoire
, les pratiques nouvelles et anciennes sont  se déroulant côte à côte
pour la toute première fois les uns à côté des
autres sur la base de racines de longue date, une nouvelle
pratique spirituelle se développe dans les
espaces urbains denses qui abritent la majeure partie
de la population mondiale, ce que j'ai
découvert lors de mon voyage de Birmingham
à Shanghai est  que les personnes super sombres
contribuent à faire de nos villes super diverses
ou de notre réseau de communautés créatives  es
du marché aux poissons à l'usine
Les habitants de Shanghai transforment
l'expérience urbaine les rituels reflètent
les désirs et les modes de la vie contemporaine
ils permettent la transmission de nouvelles idées et
traditions d'un pays à l'autre et de
génération en génération ils introduisent de
nouvelles idées
brisent les frontières culturelles et sociales
et se tailler un espace sacré privé
dans le flux de la vie quotidienne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]